now normally this is where i introduce
the guys who are on the set
but i am told and i have not seen or
heard this
that we have a special introduction
tonight to the
to the crew this can't be good it can't
be
we give you the most dominant big man of
all time the
two-time league mvp and the three-time
finals mvp
four-time champion he gave you shot in a
fool dj diesel
and even kazam sorry guys in the most
loved member on the tnt crew you may
know him as superman the big r
subtle or a shack daddy but we call him
dad
[Music]
that is special how about it thank you
oh there's more the round mound from
leeds alabama
from auburn university a man
full of guarantees
a man full of incorrect guarantees
and one of the best people i know my dad
charles barkley's
barkley
[Applause]
[Music]
oh six three guard out of
the university of north carolina by uh
archbishop malloy high school emmy
winner
gadget lover always just to the board
the man the myth the legend father of
five
and my dad kenny smith kenny
smith kenny the jedi
smith oh
five-time emmy winner bow tie wearing
husband to one father to six poppy to
four
puppies you're the best pancake maker
black masters champion and new york
times best seller
introducing danny johnson
ernie johnson jr the elevator is my son
hurting john we love you daddy
come on that was absolutely
whoever thought that jeremy anybody else
upstairs
oh man
[Laughter]
that was really good whoever idea that
was awesome
awesome